not every trap is created equal that
these films play a rigged game or some
Saw movies just better than the rest
here's our list of every sort of film
ranked from worst to best
the eighth installment slash Revival of
the saw franchise had to start fresh
after the final chapter set game over to
most the series most prolific plot
points instead of bringing back Dr
Gordon or another known name to carry
out his bidding the movie introduced a
new survivor turned killer to the phone
by jumping back 10 years to play out one
of jigsaw's old and largely unknown
group traps were introduced to Logan
Nelson a medical examiner who sneakily
investigating the cadavers of his own
victims while copycatting John Kramer's
work to deliver Justice to several
dangerous criminals and the police
officer who helped set them free of
course none of this is apparent
throughout the whole movie that's tricky
editing and clever cutaways got the
secret of Logan's true identity until
the very end after he finally ensnares
his Mark everything that's happening to
jigsaw's victim seems to be in real time
making the third act a whirlwind of
explanations and Montage moments it's a
suitable Sequel and certainly carries
forward the atmosphere in Carnage so
fans have come to know however apart
from introducing a jigsaw Super Fan
who's obviously got some some Secrets
upper sleeve worth exploring in later
pictures it barely offers anything new
and leaves some very loose threads
dangling together we built a legacy
by the time the seventh piece of the
jigsaw puzzle came into play the series
looked almost nothing like the original
detective Hoffman was so busy running
around cleaning up his own messes but
the day's game seemed like an
afterthought meant only to follow
formula in fact there were two major
group traps that were completely devoid
of value to the overarching plot whoever
thoughts it was necessary to have a man
rip all the skin off his back in 3D
might just be sicker than jigsaw while
there are a few elements of Redemption
the movie was frustratingly disjointed
Hoffman's Terminator style assaults on
the entire police department was absurd
and laid waste the entire framework of
jigsaw's Legacy Saw 3D the Final Chapter
might have been more interesting if it
focused more on Jill and Dr Gordon but
instead we got yet another full-length
Hoffman feature and since his Intrigue
had long expired by then he was left
with nothing to do except destroy
everything that made the series unique
whereas saw two's house full of victims
were mostly criminals who'd seemingly
hurts others essential figures and saw
3's round of nefariousness were
completely sympathetic the father of a
drunk driving victim was made to face
all the figures involved in the accident
that took his son and decide if they
should live or die meanwhile a trauma
surgeon later revealed to be the
cheating wife of the first victim was
tasked with keeping jigsaw alive long
enough to see things through and
ultimately became a pawn in Amanda's
test considering how sad this couple's
situation was to begin with and the fact
that there was a second poor kid caught
in the crosshairs jigsaw's elaborate
death now for each seemed particularly
cruel and contrary to any philosophical
justification he might have offered some
of the traps in this movie were
exceptionally gratuitous plus the
connective tissue needed to flesh out or
the plot was jigsaw and Amanda here was
annoyingly thick but most importantly
the choice of victims here seemed to
exhaust the whole generous Grim Reaper
identity jigsaw crafted for himself so
it lands very low on the list for that
reason
final test of forgiveness and if you are
listening to this then you
the running involvement of detective
Hoffman under the gun as he watches the
two remaining FBI agents Chase his tail
successfully sprinkled in a few key
details about the inner workings of John
Kramer's competing cohorts but by the
time the sixth film came along the Spate
of drug addicts and police officers had
somehow run afoul of John Kramer and
Company had already been killed off so
jigsaw's posthumous games carried out by
Hoffman got a bit more political a pair
of predatory loan sharks and one
particularly nasty insurance adjuster or
instead among the tested targets and
while the intention here might have been
ambitious the plot became flimsy rather
quickly the villainization of these
corporate types is tired before it even
began so the effort to pin all of the
ills of John's Insurance woes on one guy
fell completely flat it was a nice try
to find yet another thread to tag on
when it came to Jon's original ills with
the world but it became stuck shlock
long before the timer ran out he wanted
us to learn
and did you
it's strangely satisfying that saw 4
stays on the same puzzling plot path as
its predecessors and adds a new layer to
John Kramer's wretched rationale the
addition of Jill and showing John's
despair outside of the conservation
aspect was just what the series needed
to stay alive and yes we really did need
a few more secondary psychos to fill in
all the timeline gaps especially once
John Kramer had gone bye-bye I also saw
three though the central player of this
film's games Lieutenant rig seems wholly
undeserving of his trial so what if he
was passionate about his job and missed
out on a family vacation or two the
punishment never really matched a crime
in this series but especially so for reg
the clever culmination of events at the
ends delivered a fresh surprise that
saved this story The ghastiness of the
deaths on display was handily
overshadowed by the Deep dive into how
jigsaw came to be such a twisted
individual in the first place and the
fact that he still retains control of
his crew even while cold on the autopsy
table was delightfully Bonkers and
managed to renew any waning interest in
what came next but the plot's focus on
rig was lame and made this movie a very
middle of the road entry in this series
run
that's detective Hoffman embraced his
role as the lone soldier left from John
Kramer's kill Crew He had one major
problem on his hands special agent Strom
who stayed hot on Hoffman's Trail unlike
some of its predecessors saw
five-strength lay in his Precision of
Purpose with each killing the film
focused on characters that while
terrible was still smart enough to
consider pausing to use their brains
before getting right to the Trap not
only that but the game of cat and mouse
had ensued between special agent Strom
and detective Hoffman was by and large
pretty epic and hearkened back to the
first film's element of obsessive
investigation this wasn't just another
senseless police Slaughter session by
the men and women in pig masks in other
words the girl of the games too seemed
to temporarily taper off at this point
leaving a little more for the sound
effects team to color in rather than
exploiting the visual angles this film's
return to a teamwork element in the
games along with less pitiful victims
was a smart and satisfying continuation
of what made saw two stick and sram's
passionate Pursuit culminated in a
crushing twist ending that was as
jaw-dropping as anything that came
before it or after
spiral from the book of sore strips the
saw franchise down to its Basics no more
jigsaw no more Twisted convoluted
continuity it's just traps a serial
killer a menacing puppet some pig masks
and a mystery one that's in this case
may be a little too easy to solve as a
way of breathing new life into the
franchise spiral is a huge success while
its style isn't as aggressively edgy as
the first movies it's cast as bursting
with star power focusing on Chris Rock's
Scrappy detectives seek Banks instead of
the Killer and their victims offers A
New Perspective on the ever brutal sore
Universe the traps are much simpler than
the devices from the latest saw films
but they're still suitably uncomfortable
if someone less graphic the problem
spiral isn't all that scary by
emphasizing the police investigation
over everything else spiral plays more
like a police procedural or a crime
Thriller sure it's tense and the trap
scenes are full of bloody sore charm but
outside of a few jump scares you'd be
hard-pressed to call spiral a real
horror flick as a plain old movie spiral
is one of the best and most accessible
installment since the first one is it
really a superior sore experience though
the die-hard fans probably not
James Juan stepped away from the first
Sequel and Lee wanel's duties were
reduced to co-writing the script but
director Darren Lynn bausman still
managed to avoid some second verse same
as the first sequel stagnation was saw
two instead the film expanded the world
that been established in the first
installment and offered a new vein of
intrigue to explore the core idea of a
selected group of victims stuck in some
souped-up Doom room where they're racing
against the clock and fleshing out their
own shared histories completely elevated
the original idea on top of that the
Flix subplot of police brutality would
inform the rest of the franchise and the
movie gamely answered the lingering
question of what actually happens to the
survivors with the surprising return of
series Mainstay Amanda the film's
ability to merge the central test of the
day with another much more personal
challenge for detective Matthews was
very compelling worried not for the
novelty of the original film swordsu
might rank second
2023 saw eggs carried the franchise back
to its roots metaphorically and
chronologically the movie brought back
Tobin Bell as John Kramer and set its
events in between saw and saw two while
the film didn't short fans any amount of
grotesque traps it also spent some time
building an actual story Desperately
Seeking a cure for his terminal cancer
Jon lets himself get Hoodwinked by a
group of scam artists posing as
experimental doctors in Mexico City Once
John realizes what's happened jigsaw
comes out and the violence ratches up to
11. the movie contains more than a few
nods to the franchise's history but also
manages to essentially function as a
standalone film Bell gives his best
performance in the entire series helped
Along by an unusually strong Source
script the traps remain as inventive as
ever and though the film mimics the
style of the original saw it isn't
afraid to show off that the franchises
cinematography has come a long way in
nearly two decades unfortunately a few
things hold saw X back from the top slot
the movie very much advertises its twist
and the fact that it positions jigs Thor
as a hero who feels more than a little
uncomfortable like other films on this
list the biggest floor in sore X is that
it just can't quite live up to the
Nostalgia soda original by a hair sore X
lands a second best
there was something very awful about
Saul's approach to the Macabre that made
the movie such an indelible experience
it spawned an interest in seeing more of
what the messed up minds of then
industry knews Lee 1l and James Wan
could come up with in the way of those
traps from the surprisingly effective
small-scale setting of two people locked
in a bathroom playing a game of Clue for
their lives to the whirly cam Montage of
showing off other Terror traps to the
chilling sounds of Charlie Claus's
series to finding score saw opened the
door to a new horror Universe especially
after it ended on such a Twist that it
was decidedly not game over far from
perfect saw featured some moments of
imperfect acting and low budget camera
angling that are pretty cringe-worthy
upon review however even if it didn't
offer the slickest cinematography known
to Hollywood saw nevertheless presented
an original and very disturbing film
it's still number one
thank you